das ende der korona frisur die salons
dürfen wieder öffnen doch die sorge vor
einer dritten infektionswelle bleibt
schuldig im sinne der anklage
frankreichs ex präsident nicolas sarkozy
wird wegen korruption zu einer
haftstrafe verurteilt
spenden gegen den hungertod die uno
bittet die welt um hilfe für die
verzweifelten menschen im
bürgerkriegsland jemand
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen zu
einer neuen woche in der sich in sachen
shutdown wohl etwas ändern wird
neuigkeiten im sport ab heute von und
mit rudi cerne hallo guten amt es ist
montag doch in friseurgeschäften geht es
heute rund nach monatelangem shutdown
ist der andrang gewaltig nach öffnungen
lechzen aber auch viele andere
dienstleister und ihre kundschaft sie
schauen hoffnungsvoll auf mittwoch und
einen möglichen neuen corona fahrplan
von bund und ländern bayern und sachsen
aber warnen vor zu schnellen lockerungen
mit blick auf ihre grenze zu tschechien
nicole diekmann und thomas bärsch bayern
und sachsen schlagen alarm tschechien
ist nah und die nächste bund länder
konferenz ebenfalls gemeinsam werden die
beiden ministerpräsidenten erstens für
mehr impfstoff für ihre regionen und
zweitens dafür das impfkonzept insgesamt
zu überarbeiten
es wird sonst nur eine art
mangelverwaltung werden also mit einem
überbürokratisiert system kommen wir
nicht weiter deswegen spätestens april
also spätestens wenn der ganz große
anteil vom impfstoff kommt muss jede
dose impfstoff verimpft werden wo es nur
geht
große lockerungen dürften am mittwoch
keinesfalls beschlossen werden auch dies
forderten beide ministerpräsidenten
deren digitale pressekonferenz von
technischen problemen gestört wurde
wir haben jetzt die chance das modell
was wir bei unserem nachbarn sehen sei
es in österreich oder der tschechischen
republik oder auch in frankreich zu
verhindern dass wir in eine
wellenbewegung kommen öffnen schließen
fließen öffne ein ständiges hin und her
das kann niemand wollen
genau das aber passiert gerade in
kretschmers bundesland im vogtland
machen grundschulen und kitas schon
wieder dicht eltern schwanken zwischen
verzweiflung und resignation
klugscheißer reden aber nachdem man bei
einer inzidenz über 100 die grundschulen
und kitas wieder geöffnet hat war
eigentlich absehbar dass die entwicklung
dahin geht dass bei steigenden zahlen
die schulen kitas wieder geschlossen
werden müssen
wir warten eigentlich schon sein letztes
jahr langfristig
fähige konzepte und die kann man nicht
erkennen große hoffnungen ruhen jetzt
auf schnelltests eigentlich hatten sie
von heute an bereits zur verfügung
stehen sollen doch
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen
scheiterte mit seinem konzept heute nun
ein papier aus seinem hause nach
zdf-informationen schlägt er vor dass
alle bürger zwei mal pro woche kostenlos
getestet werden sollen von märz an
vorerst bis ende juni und von geschultem
personal
zwei tage noch bis zur nächsten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz gesucht
wird eine langfriststrategie im wettlauf
gegen das virus
die regierung plant also corona
schnelltests für alle
sie sollen lockerungsschritte absichern
auch aus sorge über die aktuellen
infektionszahlen so steigt die sieben
tage incidents zum ersten mal seit fast
drei wochen über 65 dessen ungeachtet
friseurtermine sind schon seit tagen
bundesweit vergriffen
daniela sonntag berichtet aus erfurt
oben 10 an den seiten 4 millimeter
endlich ein professioneller haarschnitt
ein ganz neues lebensgefühl für jörg
neblung
wie hier in erfurt darf ab heute
bundesweit wieder geföhnt und
beschnitten werden unter strengen
auflagen zehn quadratmeter pro kunde
heißt viele verlängern die
öffnungszeiten und arbeiten in schichten
in vielen bundesländern wie hier in
brandenburg öffnen heute auch wieder
floristen und gartenmärkte gärtner
erleichtert dass die früher nicht auf
den kompost müssen es sind jetzt die
haupt monate die kommen märz april mai
wir haben glück gehabt dass es zwei
ruhige monate waren wo wir zu wahren das
jetzt wo der hauptumsatz ist wir wie
offenheit und die besinnung zur natur
zum eigenen garten zum schönen balkon
wird bleiben mode händlerin anja
scheinpflug aus erfurt hat auch saison
ware im laden dass sie nicht öffnen darf
macht sie wütend
es ist hier mittlerweile eine zweierlei
maß messen und das kann einfach so nicht
mehr sein ohne uns stirbt erfuhr
dutzende einzelhändler haben derzeit
diese plakate im schaufenster
verständnis für den ärger hat auch
friseur unternehmer jens kleingünther in
erfurt und trotzdem ist der heilfroh
dass seine angestellten jetzt wieder
umsatz machen und trinken
bekommen dass wir mit die ersten sein
dürfen die öffnen
das ist also wenn ich dann die
gastronomie im vergleich sehe ist das
schon toll dass wir das sein dürfen
einziges problem überhaupt noch einen
termin bekommen die nächsten paar tage
ist hier erst mal alles ausgebucht
gartenmärkte fahrschulen oder fußpflege
jedes bundesland hat seine eigenen
regeln in unserer app finden sie eine
übersicht was öffnen darf und unter
welchen bedingungen während vereinzelt
gelockert wird breiten sich die virus
mutation weiter aus vor allem bei
unseren europäischen nachbarn
nun gilt auch das französische
département moselle als virusvarianten
gebiet wer von dort über die grenze nach
rheinland pfalz oder ins saarland will
braucht ab morgen einen negativen corona
test mindestens einen schnelltest die
grenzen bleiben offen die polizei soll
aber stichprobenartig kontrollieren
das alles gilt auch für pendler innen
susanne freitag außer brücken alles
zweisprachig in diesem testzentrum in
saarbrücken
viel zeit bleibt nicht morgen um 6 uhr
soll es losgehen
was als deutsch französisches symbol
geplant war wird jetzt zur dringende
notwendigkeit ein negativer test nicht
älter als 48 stunden pflicht bei der
einreise nach deutschland auch für
pendler ist die lösung alle zwei tage
das ist doch unlogisch soll ich jetzt
hier in der schlange stehen oder
irgendwo hinten rum fahren wenn ich zur
arbeit will
viele haben den test so was mal wir
probieren es durchfahren oder ich steh
34 stunden in der schlange
corina mörsdorf ist grenzgängerin die
französin leitet ein ausbildungszentrum
im saarländischen völklingen heute
erstmal krisensitzung weil keiner weiß
was morgen ist
deutsche und franzosen hatten gehofft
dass man sich dieses mal besser abstimmt
aber wie gesagt das vor es gab doch
extra eine deutsch-französische task
force die eine woche lang
zusammengearbeitet hat wir haben uns
gesagt die werden schon praktische
lösungen finden aber das gegenteil ist
der fall
es hat gar nichts gebracht lange
schlangen in forbach lothringen überall
dort wo man schnell noch einen test
machen kann
wer bis zur sperrstunde keinen termin
hat der fährt morgen theoretisch illegal
nach deutschland zur arbeit und in der
projektarbeiten sind wir gut genug aber
wenn es um solche dinge geht dann sind
wir franzosen doch häufig benachteiligt
wieder einmal steht die
deutsch-französische nachbarschaft vor
einer großen belastungsprobe
ein halbes jahr vor der bundestagswahl
hat die spd ihr wahlprogramm vorgestellt
einiges ist altbekannt wie die forderung
nach höheren steuern für vermögende und
die abschaffung der ungeliebten
sozialleistungen hartz 4
das soll durch ein bürgergeld ersetzt
werden anderes ist neu wie ein
tempolimit auf autobahnen
andreas huppert mit weiteren wichtigen
punkten des programms bei der spd geht
es voran nachdem mit olaf scholz schon
der kanzlerkandidat fest steht die
zuletzt auch beim wahlprogramm ruckzuck
auf knapp 50 seiten haben die
sozialdemokraten ihre ziele und
vorstellungen zusammengefasst unser ziel
ist dass wir einen plan für die zukunft
durchsetzen für deutschland die 20er
jahre beginnen und es geht jetzt darum
dass man eine zuversichtliche
perspektive formuliert wie wir
arbeitsplätze wie wir technologische
weiterentwicklung wie wir wohlstand in
deutschland organisieren können im
nächsten jahrzehnte deshalb schreibt
sich die spd so deutlich wie niemals
zuvor den klimaschutz ins wahlprogramm
grüne mobilität vom elektroauto bis zum
ausbau des schienennetzes
inklusive eines tempolimit von 130 auf
autobahnen
ich glaube auf jeden fall dass es uns
gelingen kann an der stelle eben den
klimawandel der für uns ja genauso zu
bekämpfen ist zusammen mit der
gerechtigkeits krise dass wir da starke
antworten haben ich glaube aber wir
müssen noch einen schritt weitergehen
auch wenn wir junge menschen erreichen
wollen da muss sicherlich noch mehr
passieren
in der sozialpolitik der soll hartz4 weg
dafür gibt es ein bürgergeld
familienleistungen werden reformiert
beispiel kindergeld je nach einkommen
der eltern soll es zwischen 250 und
maximal 528 euro
die vermögenssteuer wird wiederbelebt
spitzenverdiener sollen mehr steuern
zahlen drei prozent rauf ab einem
jahreseinkommen von 500.000 euro bei
verheirateten beziehungsweise 250.000
bei ledigen im vordergrund steht
entlastung der kleinen mittleren und
durchaus auch oberhalb des durchschnitts
verdienenden menschen
die spd-spitze hat ihr wahlprogramm
formuliert jetzt muss noch ein parteitag
programm und den dazugehörigen
kanzlerkandidaten bestätigen von 2007
bis 2012 war er die nummer eins im staat
heute wurde frankreichs ex präsident
nicolas sarkozy zu einer haftstrafe
verurteilt es geht um bestechung
nach überzeugung der richter versprach
sarkozy einen generalstaatsanwalt am
obersten gerichtshof einen posten in
monaco um so an geheime
ermittlungsergebnisse zu gelangen
aus paris christel hass nicolas sarkozy
gibt sich gelassen als er am frühen
nachmittag ins gericht kommt er hatte
immer seine unschuld beteuert
ich bin kämpferisch ich nehme nicht hin
dass man mir dinge vorwirft die ich
nicht begangen habe
juni bot gummis doch was ihm der richter
drinnen im saal heute verkündet ist eine
eiskalte dusche drei jahre haft wegen
bestechung und unerlaubter einflussnahme
davon zwei auf bewährung
die strafe kann er mit elektronischer
fußfessel zu hause absitzen
noch nie ist ein ehemaliger präsident so
hart bestraft worden
und darum geht es sarkozy wollte so
sieht es das gericht nach seiner
amtszeit einen generalstaatsanwalt
bestechen
der sollte ihm informationen über eine
andere affäre die sarkozy betraf
preisgeben
die justiz bekam davon wind weil sie zu
der zeit die telefonate von sarkozy und
dessen anwalt abhörte
die verteidigung hat berufung eingelegt
dieses urteil ist für uns unverständlich
und empören
vor allem im konservativen lager galt
sarkozy immer noch als hoffnungsträger
das urteil jetzt könnte die karten neu
mischen wenn er verurteilt worden ist
dann gibt es dafür gründe
es ist gut dass die justiz ihre arbeit
macht es ist absurd dass man bei allen
politikern immer alles auf die goldwaage
legt in ein paar wochen wird sarkozy
übrigens schon wieder vor gericht stehen
diesmal wegen illegaler finanzierung
seines wahlkampfs 2012 zu einem anderen
ex präsidenten donald trump seit seinem
abtritt vor knapp anderthalb monaten war
er fast abgetaucht jetzt eine art
kleines comeback entgegen der
amerikanischen tradition die ehemaligen
präsidenten politische zurückhaltung
auferlegt bei einer veranstaltung der
konservativen partei in florida holte
trump zum rundumschlag aus bescheinigte
joe biden einen desaströsen ersten monat
und wetterte gegen gemäßigte
konservative außerdem stellte er klar er
wolle keine eigene partei gründen eine
mögliche wiederkandidatur 2024 ließ
brand offen
einen monat nach dem militärputsch in
myanmar ist die anklage gegen die
abgesetzte regierungschefin augen
sanssouci ausgeweitet worden
sie muss sich jetzt auch noch wegen
anstiftung zum aufruhr verantworten
die proteste gegen die militärjunta
gingen auch heute weiter
trotz oder gerade wegen der vielen opfer
gestern
18 menschen waren am sonntag getötet
worden
wir blicken jetzt in ein land das hilfe
dringender braucht als irgendetwas
anderes
denn jemen ausgeblutet und zerrissen vom
bürgerkrieg vier kind zu sein ist eine
ganz besondere hölle sagt der
uno-generalsekretär 400.000 kinder sind
so stark unterernährt dass jeder tag ihr
letzter sein kann
bei einer geberkonferenz der uno hat
deutschland heute 200 millionen euro
zugesagt seit vielen jahren kämpfen im
jemen rebellen mithilfe irans gegen die
regierung die vor allem von saudi
arabien unterstützt wird uli gack
berichtet ahmadiyya ist stark
unterernährt ein kinder schicksal unter
hunderttausenden im jemen 13 jahre altes
das mädchen und nur 11 kilo schwer als
es in ein krankenhaus eingeliefert wurde
sagen die ärzte in sanaa
man hätte sie gerade noch vor dem tod
retten können
gerade jetzt steigen die fälle von
unterernährung es ist mehr als in den
vergangenen jahren
den armen haus der arabischen welt
dieser krieg zwischen rudi und saudi
arabien hat das wenige zerstört dass da
war die folge extreme not wenn kein geld
da ist dann müssen wir einfach bis zum
nächsten tag hungern die hilfe der
geberländer reiche oft nicht mal zum
überleben klagen hier fielen zuletzt
seien die hilfsleistungen sogar
zurückgegangen ohne milliarden spenden
der industrienationen können die un
nicht helfen ein appell an die
solidarität
wir reden heute von 16 millionen deren
ernährung nicht gesichert ist und wir
sehen mehr und mehr an der grenze zur
hungersnot 50.000 sind bereits am
verhungern
man dürfe solche furchtbare bilder aus
dem jemen nicht einfach hinnehmen sagen
mitarbeiter von hilfsorganisationen ein
ganzes volk ist in extremer not und 4
milliarden dollar seien nötig und
wenigstens das schlimmste abzuwenden
[Musik]
und gerade meldet uno-generalsekretär
görisch es habe bei der geberkonferenz
nur zusagen über 1,7 milliarden dollar
gegeben
das sei enttäuschend wenn sie spenden
wollen können sie das tun an das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf jemen hilfe
die iban lautet de 65 104 106 100 104
106 100 nachzulesen und der spenden
punkt zdf.de oder auf zdf text auf seite
8 190 zurück in den deutschen alltag bei
vielen elektrogeräten gibt es da ab
heute neues zu beachten
es geht um die eu energie labels beim
kauf kann man dort ja die effizienz des
gerätes ablesen bislang auf einer skala
von a + + + bis die irreführend fanden
verbraucherschützer
künftig gibt es daher nur noch a bis g
außerdem werden die kriterien strenger
die klasse a soll als ansporn für die
hersteller zunächst ganz leer bleiben
die neuregelung greift etwa bei
kühlschränken waschmaschinen oder
fernseher
so sieht es eigentlich aus wenn eines
der wichtigsten film festivals beginnt
die berlinale normalerweise eröffnet mit
rotem teppich internationalen stars
tausenden gästen in diesem jahr aber
alles online wie so vieles im moment
filme gibt es erstmal nur für die jury
zu sehen
über eine branche die nichts zu feiern
hat und trotzdem versucht das beste
daraus zu machen
nadia nasa licht an wieder sichtbar
werden in der stadt zum start der online
berlinale haben programmkinos bundesweit
auf ihre situation aufmerksam gemacht
wir sind jetzt seit fast einem jahr
entweder geschlossen oder durften nur
mit geringen auslastung spielen das ist
eine enorm bedrohliche lage
und so muss die 71 berlinale erst einmal
ohne publikum stattfinden
heute hat der wettbewerb begonnen um den
goldenen und die silbernen bären
die internationale jury allesamt selbst
bären gewinnerinnen und gewinner
vier der sechs sind nach berlin gereist
vorfreude und ein bisschen wehmut
helping gibt wir helfen so den filmen
etwas weiter auf der anderen seite
vermisse ich meine kollegen sehr das
publikum vermisse ich auch und diese
spezielle berlinale energie gerade
stellte regisseurin maria schrader in
einer video-konferenz ihren
wettbewerbsbeitrag vor
ich bin dein mensch über eine frau und
ihre beziehung zu einem humanoiden
roboter
ich bin top vier der 15 wettbewerbsfilme
kommen aus deutschland
auch herr bachmann und seine klasse
ein dokumentarfilm über einen
engagierten lehrer und seine quirligen
schüler aus zwölf nationen sind es ganz
großartig dass es stattfindet erstmal
aber dass wir das im sommer dann
vielleicht hoffentlich gemeinsam im kino
sehen denn im juni soll es eine
berlinale mit publikum geben wenn die
kinos vielleicht endlich wieder leuchten
dürfen ja hoffentlich der sport beginnt
mit einem tollen erfolg für eine
deutsche starterin rudi genau und zwar
im schnee gold für selina jörg bei der
snowboard-wm in rocker in slowenien die
33-jährige aus sonthofen siegt im
parallel-riesenslalom und kann damit
ihren titel verteidigen
zum zweiten mal weltmeisterin selina
jörg bestätigt in slowenien ihren
triumph von park city 2009 10 ihr
finallauf gegen sofia nati china hoch
dramatisch die russin rechts im bild
sofort in führung zunächst mit 31 damit
48 hundertstelsekunden vorsprung durch
selina jörg im unteren teil wahrlich
weltmeisterlich von tor zu tor konnte
näher ran und geht noch in führung 12
hundertstel vorsprung nach olympischen
silber 2018 das zweite wm-gold für die
überglückliche snowboarderin aus
sonthofen und wieder muss ein
bundesliga-trainer gehen fußball
bundesligist arminia bielefeld trennt
sich von uwe neuhaus eine reaktion auf
den anhaltenden abwärtstrend der
aufsteiger ist mit einem punkt aus fünf
spielen letzter der rückrundentabelle
das dfb pokal viertelfinale zwischen
zweitligist jahn regensburg und werder
bremen ist abgesagt worden die für
morgen angesetzte partie kann nach
mehreren corona fällen bei den
regensburgern nicht wie geplant
stattfinden
nach dem streit um die geplatzte
olympiabewerbung der rhein ruhr
initiative für 2032 scheinen sich die
fronten zwischen dem deutschen
olympischen sportbund und dem
internationalen olympischen komitee
immer mehr zu verhärten
nachdem das ioc festgelegt hat dass sein
favorit für die olympia
sommerspiele 2000 32 das australische
brisbane sei ist ein streit um die
verantwortung entbrannt das ganze war
nicht nur für uns deutschland sondern
auch für circa zehn weitere
internationale bewerber höchst
überraschend das ioc hat behauptet dass
der dsb für die spiele in der region
rhein-ruhr bestätigt habe keinen
weiteren dialog zu wollen
das bestreitet der dsb hatte er doch dem
ioc mitgeteilt erst nach bürgerbefragung
und mitgliederabstimmung verhandlungen
aufnehmen zu wollen
mit welchem konzept ein erneuter anlauf
genommen wird gilt es nun in aller ruhe
zu betrachten
am ende bleibt ein weiterer erfolgloser
bewerbungs versucht deutschlands und das
war's vom sportclub morgen nach nebel
wieder viel sonnenschein und sehr mild
mehr das sogleich von besten terry das
war es von uns danke für ihr interesse
im heute journal um drei viertel 10
freut sich bettina schausten auf sie und
wir sind morgen wieder für 7.7 einen
angenehmen abend für sie und machen sie
es gut
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter ein umfangreiches
hoch hält uns die wolken fern und zwar
einmal aus dem südwesten aber auch aus
dem norden haben die wolken kaum eine
chance es gibt sehr viel sonnenschein
aber bekommen es auch mit viel nebel zu
tun und er ist ziemlich dicht vor allem
in der nacht nach norden hin im
südwesten da zeigen sich die sterne bei
temperaturen bis minus 5 grad an den
alpen - drei im osten deutschlands und
+3 ganz im westen
morgen hält sich der nebel vor allem in
küstennähe längere zeit und es ziemlich
dicht auch über dem norden deutschlands
da gibt es aber dann durchaus lücken im
tagesverlauf vor allem aber richtung
mittelgebirge viel sonnenschein im
westen sehr viel sonne und auch im süden
nur an der donau kann es längere zeit
dicht bleiben mit nebel bei höchsten
temperaturen von drei grad an der ostsee
ist am kühlsten oder mildesten ganz im
westen deutschlands am niederrhein mit
17 grad und das ist sehr mild für anfang
märz
der blick auf den mittwoch zeigt uns
noch einmal ganz viel sonnenschein weil
vier bis 18 grad am donnerstag bekommen
wir es mit kalter luft aus dem norden
mit schauern und gewittern zu tun und am
freitag gibt es wieder schnee in den
mittelgebirgen ein schöner abend